we're going to begin in Ukraine where
explosions and Airaid signs have been
heard in Kiev and it's happening a South
African president said of ramaphosa and
three other African heads of state are
in the city hoping to broker peace
between Ukraine and Moscow the leaders
are due to meet Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski later on Friday
they'll then travel to Russia on
Saturday for talks with President
Vladimir Putin in Saint Petersburg now
we've got correspondence across
developments on both sides of this
conflict in a moment we're going to
speak to yolio Chapel valova in Moscow
first let's head to key for Jonah Hull
is standing by for us let's talk about
the Air Raids first of all if I remember
correctly Jonah it's very very rare for
these Air Raids to be happening a during
daytime anyway but certainly when
foreign leaders are in the city
yeah we've been trying to work that out
and can't frankly think of a single
situation uh in the past where a world
leader has been in Kiev at the same time
as Russia has launched a missile attack
on Kiev they've been Airaid alerts in
the past but those are often signify uh
missile attacks happening elsewhere uh
in the country the all clear has been
sounded this attack is over now
preliminary reports from uh the Air
Force here say that 12 missiles were
launched from the from the Black Sea a
mix of caliber and kinjal Cruz missiles
along with two reconnaissance drones all
were brought down by air defenses that
were clearly audible around the city
here and there have been reports of
damage in one Central City District and
two further north at most likely the
result of falling debris no actual
missile impacts or casualties reported
and all of that happening at the same
time as these African leaders the heads
of four countries and senior delegations
from three others were in butcher just
west of the capital here they were
visiting a mass grave the site of
alleged victims of Russian atrocities in
the very early days of the war they too
will have been all too aware of the
sound of air defenses and of the air
Alert in place and you know this
afternoon in an hour or two they'll be
here in the capital they'll be meeting
President zielinski they'll be putting
to him their peace Mission a draft
framework containing measures designed
to be the basis of dialogue to build
trust to reduce tensions but one has to
say under these circumstances hardly
ideal circumstances to be talking about
confidence building measures yeah Jonah
they're only spending a day in Kiev and
if we understand it correctly they're
only spending a day in Saint Petersburg
as well to hold those Talks Of course
Ukraine in the middle of a counter
assault itself and so clearly very
occupied is there any sense about
whether or not this effort by the
African is is going to be any sort of
success
foreign
can only imagine that the circumstances
of an Air Attack as I said in Kiev at
the same time as these leaders are
present will allow president zielinski
to Simply say how do you negotiate with
that and bear in mind as well that the
ukrainians and president zielinski have
very frequently made the point that
anything short of a full Russian
withdrawal from every inch of Ukrainian
territory including Crimea
cannot form the basis of any talks about
peace and the African leaders are
certainly not proposing that in addition
there will be questions from the
ukrainians about the extent to which
these leaders are honest brokers in all
this in particular South Africa Accused
by the U.S of funneling weapons to
Moscow that's something the South
African government says it's
investigating and also not too long ago
taking part in Seabourn drills the South
African Navy alongside the Russian Navy
Jonah for now thank you very much indeed
that's Jonah Hall talking to us from
Keith
while the Kremlin has said that
President Vladimir Putin remains open to
any discussion of a resolution to the
conflict it comes as Putin's due to
address this year's Petersburg economic
Forum our moscow-based journalist Union
Chapel valova is going to explain some
more on that so after everything that
Jonah has talked about about the the
missile attacks that are going on in
Kiev at the moment the African leaders
contingent that's in key do we know what
uh President Putin is likely to be
saying at this economic forum
exactly we're just waiting for Vladimir
Putin to speak at the plenary meeting of
the Forum and his spokesperson has given
us a sneak peek at what is going to be
discussed there so Putin is expected to
mention this special military operation
in Ukraine of course and a given
assessment of the situation in the world
as well as share some plans for the
future according to biscov President
Putin supports any ideas you mentioned
that may lead to a settlement of the
conflict in Ukraine and we also know
that he is to
um to meet the delegation of several
African leaders on Saturday so we also
know that Mr Putin has held talks with
the president of the United Arab
Emirates on the fringes of the Saint
Petersburg economic forum and he thanked
the president of the UAE for his efforts
to resolve humanitarian issues during
the events in Ukraine and called him a
very good friend and comfortable partner
for Russia while Muhammad Ben Zayed
al-narayan called Putin his friend so
basically the situation well is and well
it's developing here on the political
front so to speak yeah the other
interesting thing about this is that for
a long time President Putin did not
really travel outside Moscow and yet
he's in Saint Petersburg for this one
would imagine that there's a certain
amount of security concern for him how
is that playing out
decisions
yeah we're hearing mobile internet has
been turned off while President Putin is
at the Forum the organizers referred to
the technical works but journalists who
have inside information say that uh the
communication lines have been jammed to
prevent possible drone attacks as Putin
is due to speak in front of a large
audience there at the form of plenary
meeting but still local Wi-Fi will be
available for guests and participants
according to the organizers so no one
will be cut off from the rest of the
world the Kremlin spokesperson also
commented on the security measures
saying that they are unprecedented
they've been
sufficiently and particularly
strengthened because quote the enemy
acts arrogantly and does no leave
attempts to inflict damage end quote so
we're sitting and waiting for Mr Putin
to address the plenary session and of
course we'll bring you more details a
bit later on
from Moscow Yulia thank you very much
indeed